[Music]
this morning on the dish a pastry chef
for two presidents growing up in Ohio
Billy ocess was a lucky kid
his mother's specialty was making
delicious pies cakes and other desserts
and baking would become his passion as
well after earning degrees in both Hotel
Management and French he became a pastry
chef at top New York City restaurants
then in 2007 during the Bush
administration he was named executive
pastry chef at the White House a job he
held for seven years into the second
term of the Obama administration now
he's joined another venerable
institution as executive pastry chef at
New York's legendary Four Seasons
restaurant chef bill Yosses good morning
welcome to the dish thank you very been
staring over at this table during the
whole show
waiting to dig in what have we got so
well we could start out maybe with the
caviar and creme fraiche on purple
potatoes next you have the marinated
leeks with walnuts the mashed potatoes
are mixed with parsnips one of my
favorite vegetables and very like Ohio
basis kind of this Midwest asparagus
bagna cauda with an anchovy sauce short
ribs and of course not to forget apple
pie to finish them oh yes and we have
the mad as hell cocktail we're not gonna
take it anymore this is my favorite
cocktail name ever on the dish my name
when it comes to nicknames the crust
master that's right it was really was
was I was honored to have that that
title from President Obama yes uh-huh I
mean there's secretary of states and
there's cabinet ministers but crust
master has its own ring when you first
got the job in the White House under the
Bush administration remember getting
that call oh the call was yeah very
interesting because I thought it was a
you know fake no I was like oh yeah
whatever
they call you no no he's actually it was
the social secretary who's there on the
first lady's team and her name is
Lieberman she called me and said you
know where we need somebody here would
you be interested in working at the
White House and I was like I've heard of
the place but anyway it turned out
really wonderful a different kind of job
well it is because it combines a lot of
things you're working for an individual
family and basically you know we have
two customers and then but you also the
rest of the mission is for their guests
so that can be 500 people a day so it's
kind of like working on a hotel banquet
right as well as working as a private
chef but for you to outlast I mean not
just one I mean you transitioned into a
second president into his second term
yeah bipartisan but it's it's not that
unusual there because there's you're
part of the what's called the residence
staff which is a wonderful group of
people that don't get very much praise
they're sort of behind the scenes but
they stay from administration to
administration and they are devoted to
not only the president but the president
seemed you were particularly influenced
working with Michelle Obama yeah so mrs.
Obama early on started this garden in
the South Lawn and that was the launch
of her let's move program about
healthier eating about greater awareness
of what we eat where it comes from and
so I became like the director of the
children's tours of the garden really
now even though I grew up in Ohio I have
a black film I tried not to ruin things
in the garden that was my job but the
really fun part was giving kids tours of
this garden and learning about
bumblebees and pollination and roots and
worms and all that stuff which was
really fun
you've said your time at the White House
prepared you for work you've actually
done in the theater you've cooked for
Broadway shows yes that's right yeah so
oddly enough yeah there's sort of like a
sense of being in a scripted environment
in the white houses you can imagine like
everything has to go off exactly at the
right time and so yeah so now I'm
working for a great show called Network
yes remake of a hemisphere masters who
so the there's a restaurant on stage so
audience members can buy a ticket to sit
on stage and have a four-course meal
that night oh really yeah
and so there's interaction between the
actors on stage and the audience members
somewhat and it's the idea is to blend
what is real and what is the screen how
much of those tickets if they are over
400 well but that must be a fun it's so
much fun it's it's just a fascinating
play to begin with because the dialogue
really reverberates it's from 1976 but
you'll hear lines that could have been
written yesterday along with same lines
when you talk about the excitement of
that then you've got the four seasons
right the four seasons restaurant is
where I'm the pastry chef that's my day
job and love it it's a tonic incredible
and it closed down and now it's out yes
now it's open again it's a legendary
place from the end of the 1950s really
yeah so I think all New Yorkers kind of
feel a soft spot for the Four Seasons it
kind of invented restaurants the modern
restaurant and so we make the desserts
there and we have a fantastic chef Diego
Rivera young guy who's really I've heard
of him well we're gonna have you sign
the deal sure mhm if you can have this
meal with anyone past or present who
would it be
oh wow so many names come to mind you
know I'm I really admire this great
French chef from the 19th century
Antonin Karev so Karim was sort of like
previous cofee a but he's one of the
people that really made food into this
very celebratory wonderful moment that
people shared together that's what we
have right here I know and I clean my
plate never
that happens chef bill Yosses Thank You
thanks so much for having me and for
more on chef you can go to our website
at CBS this morning dot-com